[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact in March 2017
four men broke into a Berlin Museum and
stole a huge gold coin this was no easy
task because the coin was as big as a
manhole cover one yard in diameter and
one point two inches thick and it
weighed 220 pounds it was a specially
minted Canadian big maple leaf and one
time recognized as the biggest gold coin
in the world the coin was made from
ultra pure gold by a Royal Canadian Mint
in 2007 and had a face value of
approximately four million dollars
evidently the daring suspects broke into
the museum through an upstairs window
and used a ladder wheelbarrow and rope
to extract the coin from bulletproof
glass enclosure and transported out of
the museum
the fourth suspect was a museum guard
accused of helping them even though the
four thieves were eventually apprehended
the coin is still missing German
authorities believe that 220 pound
Canadian treasure has already been
melted down and probably will never be
recovered
you know the Bible talks about how to
find the missing coin stay where those
friends were going to learn more on this
edition of Bible answers live you're
listening to Bible answers live honest
answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 the doug
batchelor facebook page or the amazing
facts facebook page my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is Jean Ross good
evening friends and pastor Doug let's
stop the program with prayer dear father
we thank you that we have this
opportunity once again to open up your
word and study we do recognize the Bible
as being in a very special way blessed
by you and we need the Holy Spirit in
order for us to correctly understand it
so we invite your presence be those who
are listening and we ask this in Jesus
name Amen amen
Pastor Dave is always interesting when
you read about gold coins we were
actually talking before the program
about the largest gold coin in the world
currently in Australia a one ton gold
coin I was looking at a picture of it
it's very big I think you just think
about the value of gold and then to have
that much gold in one place well you can
imagine why it would be a tempting you
know idea for thieves to try and get
their hands on a gold coin it probably
melted down and used the gold elsewhere
so it's difficult to kind of trace them
yeah exactly it's a little different
than diamonds now they laser mark
diamonds where stolen diamonds can be
tracked mm-hmm throw away the gold once
you melt it down it's it's very hard to
know what the source was right but they
think this coin is gone forever
now it reminds me of a story as you
probably heard this coming from the
Bible and in Luke chapter 15 there's a
parable Jesus tells he only tells it
here in Luke or what woman having ten
silver coins if she loses one coin does
not light a lamp and sweep the house and
search carefully until she finds it and
when she is founded she calls her
friends and her neighbors together
saying rejoice with me I found the peace
which I lost likewise I say to you there
is joy in the presence of the angels of
God over one sinner who repents you
could imagine the joy if someone lost a
1-ton gold coin or a 220-pound gold coin
to have that recovered they'd be very
happy
and here this woman loses a silver coin
this is usually something the women got
during a wedding dowry in it so it's got
sentimental value as well but then the
Lord says that there's something worth
more than gold and silver and that's a
human soul and you know God gave an
infinite price that we might be redeemed
but you know while we're in this world
we do operate with gold and silver and
dollars and coins you might be surprised
10% of everything Jesus said had to do
with finances and money the Bible
actually gives some proven secrets to
succeed financially and if a person
follows these principles God promises a
blessing and we're gonna offer this
study guide The Illustrated study guide
that is filled with biblical information
on the secrets to a success financially
and anyone who asks for it tonight
it's called In God We Trust if you'd
like to receive a free copy of this
amazing fact study guide the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven that is the
resource phone line and you can answer
the study guide called in god we trust'
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven and if you have a Bible question
our phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven why
would that be ready to go to our first
caller this evening we have Chris
listing in Florida Chris welcome to the
program yes thank you very much yeah and
your question tonight can you hear us
yes yes my quest
from Chios he blew six
there's his soul and sigh would you like
me to read that for folks yes please for
it is impossible for those who were once
enlightened and have tasted the heavenly
gift and have become partakers of the
Holy Spirit and have tasted the good
word of God and the powers of the age to
come if they fall away to renew them
again to repentance seeing they crucify
to themselves the Son of God and put him
to an open shame now are you wondering
does this mean does this mean once a
person is a Christian if they backslide
can they be saved
alright well let's ask that question is
this first saying that if a person is
walking with the Lord and they backslide
can they be saved well do we have
examples in the Bible of people that
were walking with the Lord that were
spirit filled that back slid but were
saved we know the story of David David
was anointed with the Holy Spirit filled
with the Holy Spirit walking with God he
back slid in a pretty major way when he
turned from God sinned with Bathsheba
killed her husband or had him killed and
did David repent and was he forgiven yes
you've got Peter who walked with the
Lord went out preaching teaching and
then he denied even knowing the Lord but
Peter he went out he wept bitterly and
he was forgiven other other kings in the
Bible like Manasseh Manasseh is I don't
know how saved he ever was to start with
but he was in the end you have examples
in the Bible of people who walked with
the Lord and then they back slid in a
major way
but then they came to their senses they
repented and they were forgiven Solomon
did that mhm later in life in the book
of Ecclesiastes he repents you know okay
posture one more quick question the
difference is there a difference between
to be saved and to be born again well a
person is saved when they are justified
by faith theoretically at that point
they are born again now you might not
see the evidence of the new birth if a
person is saved in the last hours
of their life like the thief on the
cross but you know when they believe by
faith God gives them a peace and a new
heart and I would say every safe person
should be a born-again person because
jesus said unless you are born of the
water in the spirit you cannot enter the
kingdom of heaven you must have the new
birth that makes sense
hey we thank you so much appreciate that
Chris we hope that you'll send for our
study guide that talks about the new
birth and it's three steps to heaven
you'll enjoy that all you left to do is
just call the number eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and ask
for the book called three steps to
heaven we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks our next
caller that behalf is a sane listening
from La saying welcome to the program
hello hi you're on the air okay my name
is Sean Oh from Los Angeles okay hi hi
hi buster I have a question for you yes
can I get my side to school a need or an
activity well when you say tithe the
Bible speaks of two different tides
there was one tithe that was taken up
every three years and it was given to
the poor of the land it was during some
of the feasts they could use that for
some of the expenses of travel and and
other things the Lord laid on their
heart then there was a ongoing tithe
that was given for the support of the
full-time ministry if you take a tithe
what would they would call that your
second tithe there'd be nothing wrong
with giving that to the school you
wouldn't want to take the money that is
satisfied set aside for the storehouse
and be reallocating that because just
suppose for a moment if every member of
the church was to take the money that
your regular tithe and they say well
this month on ascending it here I'm
sending it there pretty soon the
pastor's are out of a job you're not
said missionaries are not doing their
work I'd say that that would come from
offerings or what they call a second
time oh by the horse I have to go to the
I have to bring it to my my church there
huh yeah you did want to have if you're
going to a church every every
can they're depending on a particular
budget I think it's good to be
systematic in that now you know if a
person is impressed or they make an
exception every now and then I don't
know that light means going to come down
from heaven as a rule I would say that's
typically a good policy oh yeah yeah
because I saw pasta and our church and
the judges I I go yeah it's already
there is a big big big church and it
already ended I in other place in my
country it is open I couldn't for poor I
said oh my the school is so poor but our
school you know our church school church
school and then they really did I said
maybe I can breathe I can save my life I
to to that school because anyway that
just that I'm going now it's very very
rich I mean yeah the church in yeah yeah
I'd say you know if God's Spirit is
impressing you otherwise you would
really enjoy the lesson that we're
offering tonight it talks about that and
we'll send you a free copy of that all
you'll need to do is just give us a call
on our resource phone line it's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and you can ask for that study
guide called in god we trust' next
caller that we have his bill listening
from Illinois bill welcome to the
program
hi thank you for taking my call yeah I
have a question about the crucifixion of
Jesus he was crucified between two
thieves and initially they both reviled
him but before Jesus gave up his spirit
one of the thieves in some sense
repented or something yes I can't find
it in the Bible
exactly and I'd like to know what
exactly it was that thief said to Jesus
I'll read it to its Luke chapter 23 and
verse 43 Luke has some of the longest
chapters in the Gospels and it says when
Jesus is dying on the cross and a matter
of fact you might want to start with
verse 39 then one of the criminals who
were hanged Blass famed him and said if
you are the Christ save yourself and us
but the other answered rebuking him
saying do you not even fear God
senior under the same condemnation and
we indeed justly for we receive the due
reward of our deeds but this man has
done nothing wrong then he said to Jesus
Lord remember me when you come into your
kingdom and Jesus said to him
assuredly I say to you you will be with
me in paradise
now Christ was on the cross for about
six hours alive and when he was first
crucified I think both of the thieves
were saying you know can't you save us
he saved other people but as one of
those thieves hung there and he heard
Jesus say my God my God why have you
forsaken me and Christ was quoting from
Psalm 22 and Psalm 22 says they pierced
my hands and my feet and he started
thinking well here he is his hands and
his feet are pierced and it says they
gambled for my clothing and they gambled
for his clothing he saw the sign above
the head of Jesus this is the king of
the Jews
his mind was quickened by the Holy
Spirit and he began to believe so in
those hours something was happening to
him and even in the closing hours of his
life he turned to Jesus for mercy and
that man will be in heaven well wait
What did he say to Jesus remember me
when you come into your kingdom
yes did he say something else did he say
Lord yes he did he said Lord remember me
that's verse 42 there it is there it is
Lord he called him Lord yep just like
all of us yep you've got it so he not
only acknowledged Jesus as Lord he
acknowledged Jesus as king and keep in
mind when he called Jesus Lord and King
he did not look like a lord and Akane
Christ was hanging there beaten and
bleeding and virtually naked and his own
apostles were standing at a distance
afraid but this man testified that Jesus
was a Lord and a king you know I've got
a message that talks about the thief on
the cross are actually it's called
crucified with Christ it's a special
gift book I'd like to give you a free
copy of that bill it's called crucified
with Christ and we'll be happy to send
that to you the number to call is 808
three five six seven four seven after
the book called crucified with Christ
we'll be happy to send that to you bill
Oh anyone who calls and asks next caller
that we have is Michael listening from
listening California Michael welcome to
the program well thank you very much
and I'm I'm a longtime listener
first-time caller and I have a question
that's been kind of I don't know
puzzling me for at least a month now I
don't anyway assuming that God and it's
probably more than assuming but God was
able to see everything into the future
and so he had to have known that that
mankind was going to suffer and so I'm I
can't understand why he would create us
if he knew that we were gonna suffer so
much
well yeah God does know all things but
God also does not force everything in
order for him to have a universe where
people genuinely love he cannot
manipulate circumstances so that
everybody is forced to love him God will
create creatures even though he knew
that these creatures might disobey and
she's something else now the terrible
battle with sin that's happening during
this very brief episode in history keep
in mind there were millions of years
before man was made that God existed and
there will be millions of years after
this experiment with sin that will live
in eternity the painful war that's going
on now between good and evil is assuring
that this will never happen again
so he allowed it to happen to
demonstrate what the results of sin are
and what his characters really like
mm-hmm
so he kind of had to do it so okay so I
guess it gets down to even more basic
than that what was the reason he create
I'm you know I haven't lost my faith I I
know there are some things that can be
answered but why would even create us in
the first place was he lonely or was he
you know did he want companionship or
whitey why why even create us in the
first place well God is love
and I believe that God wants others he
likes to give joy and happiness
he creates beans and to share that love
to share the glory he wants us to enjoy
it he loves and he wants to be loved no
doubt
I think you know the Bible says every
good and perfect gift is from God well
it's kind of like why would a mother
have a baby and a lot of mothers if
they're having any problem boy they go
to great lengths to visit the fertility
clinic they want so much to have a baby
it's like they feel like I was designed
for this purpose I want to have a child
not every mother but most it's in order
to be a mother you have to have a baby
yeah but they realize when they have
that baby there's a risk that baby may
not love them back and there may be
problems and but they want so much to
love the baby and to be loved that
they're willing to take that risk man is
made in the image of God God probably
shares in some of those sentiments right
okay well I'm you know I I still I'm
kind of wondering why well you know I I
guess is there something we're gonna
have to ask him when we get when we see
him during the Millennium are you where
you can write something down I'm sorry
what why are you driving or can you
write something down oh no I can write
something down hang on just and this is
for anybody out there are you ready
there's a the YouTube you can watch
produced by amazing facts called cosmic
conflict it explains the very questions
you're asking about if if God is love if
God is good then why is there so much
evil go take a look at cosmic conflict
on amazing facts website and I think
you'll find that a real blessing anyone
out there who's asking these questions
tells about the origin of easel evil and
why God allowed this journey back
through time to the center of the
universe discover how a perfect angel
transformed into Satan the arch villain
[Music]
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
immunity that moved to earth behold the
creation of a beautiful new planet and
the first humans witness the temptation
of evil discover God's amazing plan to
save his children this is a story that
involves every life on earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
four life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm a next caller
that we have is Jaime listening from
Kentucky Jamie welcome to the program
yeah what do you think about Zionism in
the Christian churches because that star
of David is really the star of remphan
it says in the Bible it says in the
Bible it's the star of what RAAM RAAM
where do you read that
if there's a he send them into a
wilderness and they was worshipping
idols and stuff so he give them a star
there God Ram RAM yeah I don't know that
that's the Star of David though that
it's talking about but anyway but you're
asking about Zion isn't made that you
know where the Star of David came from
it is true that there's no evidence that
the Star of David was ever used by
Solomon or David that's an ancient
symbol that's been probably you'll find
that design of two triangles
intersecting all over the world and I've
been in India where I've seen it in
architecture in other parts of the world
so it's not a new geometric shape but is
your question really about Zionism or
that particular shape of their star
Zionism in the church what do you think
about it well believing that God has a
special purpose for Israel I don't see
any harm in that I do think that
sometimes the church goes to extremes
one extreme I hear is where the church
they believe that all the prophecies in
the
regarding Israel are all over that God
has no plan for the Jews now that's one
extreme and that's a replacement
theology and then you've got the other
extreme which is that ever all these
prophecies about Israel are only literal
Israel I do think if you read the New
Testament you can't escape that many of
the prophecies were Christians were
grafted into the stock of Israel and
that every Christian sort of becomes a
spiritual Jews now God still has a plan
for Israel because Paul said I would
wish that all Israel might be saved and
the Bible says Jerusalem will be trodden
down by the Gentiles until the times of
the Gentiles be fulfilled so the Lord's
not taking his eyes off his people we
mustn't miss that every believer the
Bible says if you are Christ then you
are Abraham's seed now I've got a book I
can send you on that Jamie if you'd like
a free copy
it's called spiritual Israel and I wrote
that with a Jewish friend of mine Steve
Wahlberg and it's got some great
information number to call for that he's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again asked for the book
called spiritual Israel eight hundred
eight thirty five six seven four seven
have you ever wondered how can I share
Jesus with my Jewish friends amazing
faxes recently produced a fascinating
three-part DVD series called is Jesus
kosher for Jews in these new programs
three Jews Steve Wahlberg Jeff sir
Minsky and myself relate our personal
encounter with a Christian faith so pick
up a copy today for yourself and share
one with your Jewish friends call 800
five three eight seven 275 or visit us
at 8 F bookstore com to get yours next
what would that be heavies sanu
listening from looks like Nebraska Cindy
welcome to the program Thank You Heidi
I'm excited thank you for having me on
the call today yeah I've listened for a
lot of years and this is first time I'm
calling so I'm excited to to get my
question a is that I've searched for it
all day because I had a friend that
asked me this question I had shared a
video that Pastor dug on the Witch of
Endor and um she had a question about
Luke 22
forty-three and how you explain you know
Jesus answer that verily will be with me
today yes could you explain sure now
this is great because we just had a
question a minute ago where a person was
asking about Luke chapter 23 the thief
on the cross Jesus said to him surely I
say to you today you will be with me in
paradise
now some translations say they put the
comma assuredly I say to you , today
you'll be with me in paradise
many translations do that that makes it
sound like the thief was in paradise
with Jesus that day well that's not
possible because when you get to John
chapter 21 and Mary is at the
resurrection and she goes to worship
Jesus Jesus said do not cling to me for
I have not yet ascended to my father now
that's Sunday morning how could the
thief be with Jesus Friday afternoon
yeah if Jesus hasn't been there yet so
the solution is what Christ is really
saying assuredly I say to you today I'm
making a promise today that you will be
with me in paradise it's not the
emphasis today you're with me in
paradise but today I'm making a promise
I think it's pretty clear the thief
wasn't in paradise with Jesus that day
he's talking about I'm making a promise
even though I don't look like a king I
don't look like a lord I'm telling you
today you're gonna be with her with me
in paradise
because one of the things to bear in
mind he's original all-greek that the
New Testament was written and did not
have punctuation that was added later on
with the translation when they did the
translation so you know sometimes they
inserted a comma in this particular text
probably would have been better for them
to put it after the word today than
before but that's not in the original
quick story years ago you still with me
is he new yes I'm here thank you years
ago before they had telephones they used
to use Western Union and this lady of a
wealthy millionaire she was over
shopping in Paris and she sent her money
her husband a Western Union telegram
used to pay by the letter back then it
said found beautiful mink coat would
like to buy okay
and he sent a telegram back and he said
no price too high so she bought the coat
well when she gets off the boat after
her vacation he sees her sporting this
new mink coat and he said I told you not
to buy it she said no you told me no
price too high he said no no I said no ,
price too high and so the changing of
that comma gave the complete opposite
meaning right it's about the placement
of the collars yeah punctuation makes
all the difference in the world
okay well thank you so much I appreciate
you reading that
thank you and you know what people also
struggle with the adverse we're talking
about baptism for the dead
that's another punctuation problem that
gets the people in deep water
we got 54 seconds Pastor Ross tell you
what why don't we talk about something
else until we take our break and then
we'll we'll pick up our callers friends
we're not going away we always have to
take a half time break and we'll do that
in just a moment want to tell you right
now that our free offer for tonight is
talking about In God We Trust Christian
principles for faithfulness in funds how
to prosper and to be blessed through the
following those principles if you like a
free copy of In God We Trust
what's the number a number two Coley's
800 eight three five six seven four
seven ask for the study guide called in
god we trust'
or just go to the amazing facts website
amazing facts dot o-r-g or.com yeah and
we got a lot of other information at the
amazing facts dot o-r-g
website take a look we'll be back with
more questions momentarily
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
we know we're here but we're not here
for very long so the most important
thing would be if we could learn during
this life how to live forever this is
the central focus of amazing facts I
think it's very important for us to
build churches but if the churches lose
the message of salvation they just
become buildings and shells I think it's
important to have a medical ministry and
build hospitals but if they separate
that from the message of salvation you
just prolong a sinners life for a little
while that's why for years amazing facts
has made it our focus to present the
saving truth that sets people free and
Friends we want to thank you for your
support in your gifts we'll do our very
best to convert those resources into the
currency of heaven may God bless you and
keep amazing facts in your prayers
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 for seven once again that's
800 eight three five six seven four
seven now let's join pastors Doug
Batchelor and John Ross for more Bible
answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you have a Bible
question once again that number 804 6
372 97 that's 800 god says and you can
also be tuning in there it is you can
watch on either the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page or the amazing facts
Facebook page and see such as it is our
humble settings here in the studio why
we try to answer your Bible questions
and my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross we have another caller Sibiu
listening from Kentucky Sabeel welcome
to the program about the Gargan process
John Ross thank you for taking my call
yeah your question yes my question is is
it biblical to put a national tribe
or some sort of you know identical when
we giving the de non-denominational name
you mean like if you were to say the the
Alabama or the Farmington First Church
of Christ or something like that are you
is that what you're asking like you're
including the estate or as ever you mean
no like a national like if it is a
Russian or Russian or a tribal you know
in a giving in a denominational name in
front of that well you know the the
reason for denominational names is to
just create understanding of what group
that is to avoid confusion
unfortunately different churches have in
different places in different countries
sometimes they often have some different
teachings and people want to know well
which one are you because I want to go
to this one of this teaching and so even
some of the the national names in front
of churches have come out of some of
these differences there's no sin per se
in using some title of clarification on
what that church denomination is well
are you worried that it's you're not
supposed to have any kind of name no
what I'm saying is like for example if
let's say even 70m of this denomination
we oh is it biblical to put like a
national or a tribal in front of that
name or a different denomination is it
biblical
because for me like I'm confused you
know yeah I don't know that it's
unbiblical let's suppose you're gonna
say this is a an Ethiopian Baptist
Church well there's a lot of people from
a different culture they speak a
different language they might fear you
be very comfortable sitting in a service
where they can understand better there's
no sin in doing that
are you worried there might be some
moral dilemma or could be yes because
you know like it could it cause you know
other people at the you know class
different you know like oh this is my
group or that type of could it cost is
it biblical or my my concern is it may
be good that's all I don't think
churches should be divided racially but
I do understand here in Sacramento for
example we're an international City we
have Korean churches we have Samoan
churches we have Fijian churches we have
Chinese churches and people go to those
places because they often come from
overseas the culture the language is
different it's hard for them to
understand American services and so I
don't think there's any problem in
saying that this is you know the local
Korean Methodist Church or whatever you
know if someone is separating their
church by saying to come to this church
you got to be a certain shade of brown
or white well that's different that's
that's racism but where it's dealing
with a language and a culture so that
people can understand I don't see a
problem with that all right thanks for :
next photo that we have is David
listening from Mississippi David
laughing with the program hey a little
pasta hey thank you for calling Dennis
oh this is David David I'm sorry yeah
and your question my question is about a
forgiving as understand that the Bible
says forgive one another go to forgive
you but my main point is how you gonna
get away if you forget the person we see
not gonna see you but other thing it is
what happened between of you it will
bother you I will still come in your
mind how do you overcome so you cannot
remember the puzzle so that in to
overcome it's what happened between you
or is she well when God asks us to
forgive it's a choice that you make it
doesn't mean that you can forgive now
God can choose to you know not remember
something if he wants to God can do
anything for you and me it's a little
harder to forget especially if we've
been deeply hurt or wronged but we can
choose not to dwell on those things we
can choose to forgive that person now if
a person has taken advantage of you and
they've got a bad habit of doing that
you can forgive them and just you don't
have to do business with them anymore
you don't always have to associate with
people but you can choose not to be
bitter because you know
think about all that God has forgiven us
it's like that parable in Matthew 18 God
has forgiven us 10,000 talents we have
no right not to forgive one another and
so you choose not to think about it if
it comes into your mind you put it out
you didn't say no I've chosen to forgive
that person and you'll find peace it
definitely can be done Dennis our David
sorry everyone listening knows what I'm
talking about we've all been hurt and
sometimes you know if I ask you to think
about something someone has done that
really hurts you most people don't have
to think very long and they can think of
something we remember pain it seems to
be easy to remember you find so much
relief when you just say I'm gonna let
that go
I'm not gonna let that problem define my
life with bitterness you move on
otherwise it becomes an anchor around
your joy and just keeps you from having
any peace you know I've got a message
David online where I talk about 70 times
7 if you look up Doug Batchelor 70 times
7 there's a special message I did
dealing with forgiveness and I think it
I think you'll find it a blessing you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific Time call us at
one eight hundred seven is listening
from Vacaville Dennis Wofford the
program I took on the challenge instead
of skipping the begets as me and so many
people do just to study the Young's
concordance right down the line huh
I was surprised they not Saints they're
sinners
that's an anything that represented us
but when I got them verse eight Jehoram
began whose eyes as I am yeah I found by
going through the Youngs concordance
that there's two generations in between
those two people they did beget them
but there's two generations that has
been skipped over and the 14 and the 14
I've triggered that out even though it
looks like that's a problem it's in
there but what I found in the two that
are missing is that it seems to be is
that right in and around the time of
King Ahab and Jezebel and supposedly
their daughter a celaya
coming down from the kings of Israel and
marrying into I guess it's in verse 8
- oh Ram I believe are you wondering why
it seems there's a generation I want to
kind of coalesce your question here for
people listening are you you're
wondering why there's a generation it
appears to be missing between joram and
Isaiah I know and it is it shift because
it seems that Jezebel might be one of
the grandmother's great-grandmother's
through at the laia now I think you made
some of these names in the Bible there
was more than one
there's more than one Jeroboam there's
more than one Jerome I believe and I
think there's more than one sometimes a
has ayah is called as aza
or Isaiah and I think that when you're
seeing the genealogy of Christ there's
no missing teeth there I believe it's
it's contiguous well I'm not sure what
you're finding in the Young's
concordance but when you go into the Old
Testament I think it says that joram is
the father of oz' now when you go to
Kings and you go to Chronicles they
cover some of the same time period they
often use different names for the king
say something the Kings had a couple of
different names it's like you know the
answer from you yeah well when we talk
about American presidents some people
say John Kennedy and some people
actually call him Jack Ken
so they had a couple of different names
that were very similar that they used to
address these kings but I I've got
several Bible chrononaut chronologies
and I find in the ones I look at that it
is contiguous that joram was the father
of aza Isaiah who was the longest
reigning king of Judah our second
longest Manasseh was the longest
reigning 55 years as I was 52 years and
boy be something to have a president
that long but yeah that's just before
the time of Isaiah the prophet alright
well thanks you know I'm just I'm still
thinking pardon me Dennis we you asked a
good question amazing facts has a Bible
timeline we'd like to recommend that you
go to the amazing facts Bible timeline
it's simply Bible history.com you can
click there and I think it has the
Secession of the Kings Bible history com
great website did you know that Noah was
present at the birth of Abraham okay
maybe he wasn't in the room but he was
alive and probably telling stories about
his floating zoo from the creation of
the world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word go deeper visit Bible
History com4 life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com next
for that we have Anthony listening from
New York Anthony welcome to the program
yeah good evening pastor evening sorry
to give you a false alarm there I'm not
a problem so I was reading through
Romans are studying in depth Romans 11
and I got to the verse verse 23 well
basically you know Romans 11 talks about
you know spirit I think you mentioned it
earlier yeah mother Cheers there
you know those that did not believe in
Christ were cut off the branches that
were cut off and the Gentiles were
grafted in but it in verse 23 it says
and they also is talking about the Jews
if they still in unbelief shall be
graffed it is
for God is able to graft them in again
so my question is obviously the Bible
also says in Romans that if you confess
with your mouth that Jesus is Lord and
believe in your heart that God raised
him from the dead you'll be saved so in
order for Israel to be grafted back in
they would obviously have to accept
Christ so there I know that there are
different denomination different groups
of I guess Jews I don't want a mission
you know denominations but right that do
Polly Christ with that he a group that
can be considered fulfilling Romans 11
yeah well I think Paul was is also
saying any individual Jew not even
speaking of him as a nation any
individual Jew that accepts Christ
because it's people that believe it's
not a nation so much
they are grafted in they become part of
that that stock of Israel once again now
it could be there will be a great
revival in Israel among the Jews and
that God will begin to bless the nation
and you know you'll have many that would
be grafted in but still it's God saves
people individually if my whole country
turns to Christ and I don't being an
American it's not going to save me
nobody is saved because of their
citizenship earthly citizenship you see
what I'm saying I do
seeing it around and I see this you know
the signs of you know different churches
or gatherings where there are Jews I
believe in Christ I didn't know if we
were witnessing the fulfillment of
Romans 11 so that's not just what I was
wondering but I understand I think we're
gonna see some amazing things happen in
the last things I think there's going to
be a revival among the Jews that many
will come to a knowledge of Christ
it may take persecution and it may take
some national international catastrophe
to do that God's not forgot his promise
to Abraham and beyond that I even think
that you're gonna see millions of
Muslims coming to Christ in the last
days who are descendants of at least
spiritual descendants of Ishmael hey we
appreciate
question Anthony and you would also
enjoy that book called spiritual Israel
we mentioned earlier I hope you'll send
for a free copy my next photo that we
have is many listening from New York
many welcome to the program good evening
Panthers evening so I had it's kind of
its kind of key questions so here we go
so the church that I attend they have a
a woman pastor I just wanted to know if
this um because it's kind of on my mind
you know and I just wanted to know this
okay for this woman pastor to baptize me
and also to marry me
well biblically and that's what we need
to go by
there's no example in the Bible of a
woman officiating in these gatekeeping
functions of a pastor elder or apostle
there's no example of a woman offering
sacrifice in the Bible though no woman
that we women were baptized but there's
no record of a woman baptizing in the
Bible or performing a marriage ceremony
you do not have ordained women pastors
Jesus chose men even when the Deacons
were chose he chose men and that doesn't
mean a woman can't be serving as a
servant in a church but the Deacons had
a little more of a spiritual oversight
they even went out baptizing like Philip
the Bible says an elder needs to be the
husband of one wife it's hard for a
woman to be a husband right so and the
elders were the pastors I you know I've
got a book I can send you on that and
it's called women in ministry has all
the bible scriptures on this principle I
personally I would not feel like it was
biblical to have a woman officiate in a
baptism or a marriage yes thank you for
for that pastor appreciate you I truly
believe in your judgment well hope you
don't go by me but I do hope you'll send
for the book and take a look you know
it's always boils down to one thing is
do we find one example in the Bible just
one Bible is a big book of a woman
serving in the capacity of a pastor
apostle priest elder there's no example
there's no work that you do have women
that were prophetess you do have women
that were teaching
preaching but not those other
gatekeeping or officiating functions
thank you very much Anthony all right
thanks Manny for your call again the
book that pastor Doug mention is called
a woman in ministry will be happy to
send that in any when it calls and ask
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven next caller that we have is Vicky
listening in Ohio
Vicky welcome to the program hi how are
you tonight good thank you for calling
Vicky pastor Todd my question is is
there any scriptures that speaks of
cremation after death well the closest
we can find first I need to let you know
in most cases in the Bible when people
died they were buried it says you know
Abraham Isaac Jacob they were all buried
Joseph said take me back and bury me in
the Promised Land Jacob said the same
Rachel was buried beneath a dope tree in
Bethlehem there are a couple of cases
where some people were cremated it
wasn't the first choice it was the
second choice when Saul's body was
pinned on the walls along with Jonathan
they died in battle their bodies were
pinned on the walls of Beth Shan the
Philistine occupied city the men of
jabba Gilead rescued the bodies and they
burned them now I'm sure that Jonathan's
going to be in heaven many martyrs
through history have been burnt at the
stake for their faith or are we to think
well god can't resurrect them since they
were burned absolutely not God's not
using the old material he's gonna create
a new person typically Christians
practice burial because they thought
even in death man retained something of
the image of God and there was something
sacred about that and that's why Joseph
had Jacob embalmed and Joseph was
involved they tried to preserve the body
as well as they could I don't think I
don't think that person being cremated
is going to prevent God from
resurrecting them I'm just giving you
what the Bible says there's no scripture
that says thou shall not creamy all you
have there's what they call
circumstantial evidence they typically
buried so does that help or does that
confuse things that help it's a good
question we got that question a lot and
I wish I could give people a scripture
one way or the other but the Bible just
gives us examples there
well thank you so much thanks so much
god bless Vicki night bye-bye you too
appreciate it
my next caller that we have is Erin
listening from South Carolina's air and
welcome to the program
doing great in your question yes so
about nine years ago I felt called by
the Holy Spirit into the job that I'm in
now I've been doing it for eight years
had to get the education for it and
about two to three years ago I really
felt like I'm being lit in another
direction
and I've been working on getting
education but as far as anything else
going it's just not panning out but I
really feel like this is what I'm I'm
being called to do and I'm wondering how
long I should keep working towards this
but never though well if you believe
that God is putting it on your heart if
you sincerely believe the will of God is
leading you in that direction and don't
give up easy yeah I can think of some
things God's put on my heart and it took
years for it to materialize but I just
really impressed it was of the Lord do
you mind my asking what the career is or
is that kind of something you want to
keep personal it's emergency
preparedness and I work yeah nothing
wrong with that if you feel that's
something God's calling me I mean know
if you were telling me I'm thinking of
going into moonshine I'd say well we
need to talk God's not leading you into
that but but you know that may be
something God is calling you into and if
it's a dream Bible says in Psalms 37
he'll give you the desires of your heart
that's because when you surrender your
heart to the Lord he will place desires
in your heart but you don't give up easy
it took years for David to go from being
a shepherd after he was anointed it was
years before he became king you know if
it's a dream he's given you can I send
you a book it's on how to know the will
of God I'd like to send you a free copy
of that would that be okay all you got
to do is call this number
no one's gonna harass you or knock on
your door and bother you but we'll just
send you the book if you call they'll
get your address and send it to you the
number to call is 800 eight three five
six seven four seven and again just
after the book called determining the
will of God that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven D G new
amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling 184 for 257,000 that's
one eight four four two one five seven
thousand we've got Lucy listening in
Canada Lucy welcome to the program hello
hi my question pastor Doug this God can
do healing miracles today since last he
did many miracles like 2,000 years ago
with Jesus walking the earth and
performing healing from people oh yes
absolutely
now you know I I maybe have never seen
anybody risen from the dead but I've
heard of it happening in other parts of
the world
I have firsthand seen in Pastor Ross and
I have both seen incredible miracles of
healing even in our own congregation
people that were you know pronounced
with a very severe form of cancer and we
prayed and there was an anointing and
and the test results were reversed one
lady is in our church every week and we
were at her hospital bed and family was
wanting me to have a final prayer and
and she was on a respirator and looked
like she had had a terminal stroke and
we prayed for her that night she sat up
and just she was fine she this has been
3 or 4 years ago so I mean I've seen
wonderful examples of healing we believe
in it okay I was just wondering because
I've been asking for healing and I know
that God has done the small miracles in
my life such as for example unscrewing
some bolt that's been really screwed in
and unable to unscrew it
it has loosened up and where it came out
easily as that's been done for me a few
times as I've been doing a small God
does big miracles are you wanting you
wanting prayer for healing yes I do all
right
you don't need to tell us what the the
nature of the problem is but if it's
okay with you Lucy will pray for you
right now
thank you Father in Heaven we just want
to come before you
and we want to pray for Lucy she's got a
burden on her heart she's praying for
physical healing Lord we know that you
were able to heal and we pray that you
will perform healing for her help her to
feel relief if there's anything she can
do in the way of pursuing medical help
sometimes you heal through through
doctors and treatment and guide her in
those decisions and we know you can also
heal supernaturally and Lord if if it's
not your will and you may choose to heal
Lucy in the resurrection with a
glorified body we know you'll heal then
as well but all things are possible with
you we still believe that Lord and we're
asking for this in Jesus name Amen amen
well Thank You Lucy I don't know pastor
else we got two minutes you want to try
real quick call who you pick one all
right we'll go to let's see I think the
next call that we have is Steve
listening in Canada we have just a few
minutes Steve Wang with the program yes
you're a good evening I appreciate
everything that you do in the name of
God and I'm watching it for years
I have one question thank you my friends
answer is the National Sunday law I
heard getting to be scared in about
three months or less this year is
supposed to sign in the the trauma
government is there any truth in that
all right let me just explain for our
listeners that many believe that in
prophecy that in the same way different
governments have made laws that would
force Christians to break one of God's
law like in Daniel chapter three he had
to worship they had to worship the image
for Daniel chapter six they could only
pray to the king in the last days that
there's going to be a law regarding the
fourth commandment that will force
people to worship a certain way
I've heard rumors I've not seen anything
Karen and I were and we're in the White
House and got a religious liberty
briefing last November there's nothing
on the horizon that I've heard of where
they're making a Sunday law that's
coming out of the current administration
I would not worry about that Steve I
think it may come some day but I don't
see it on the horizon imminently matter
of fact it's more happening in Europe
right now I've seen things in in Poland
and some of the other countries Bulgaria
all right listening friends we want to
thank you so much
calling in you know Bible answers live
has been on the air for over 20 years
we're only here because some of you
listening believe in what's happening
here and you support us if you'd like to
do that just go to amazing facts dot
o-r-g you can click that little button
says support donate and keep us on the
air thank you so much we'll study next
week together
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts when Susan's and
Michael's whirlwind relationship led to
a wedding they had no idea how hard
married life could be before they knew
it they were on the stormy path towards
divorce but that's when God led them to
an amazing fax broadcast and there they
saw the biblical view of marriage as
presented annoying Jesus
finally they understood what it meant to
love sacrificially like Christ and today
Susan and Michael are joyfully married
sharing what they learned with others
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today and to make an
eternal difference for more people like
Michael and Susan you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that you've
learned and it's easy to make a donation
just visit give dot amazing facts or RG
or send your gift to p o-- box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight you can also give us a call
at eight seven seven five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one thank you for tuning in to Bible
answers live and don't forget to share
with others the amazing Bible facts you
have learned here today written by the
hand of God
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to 75 or visit AF bookstore
com4 life-changing christian resources
visit AF bookstore com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF Axio RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 packs o RG did you enjoy
this program make sure to tell your
family and friends tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
[Music]